how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
Avengers in game has officially hit
digital you can now own it on digital HD
and as I mentioned the other day with
the release of it on digital we now know
a lot more information about the movie
we have deleted scenes and commentaries
from the directors the producers and the
actors themselves so in this video I'm
gonna go ahead and break down all of the
deleted scenes for Avengers in game that
have come out with a digital release
also be sure to subscribe to my channel
like the video and comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 so of course
one of the deleted scenes is one that
I've already done a video on it's of
Tony Stark dying and then all of the
Avengers and heroes that are on the
battlefield take a knee out of respect
to him like I said I did a full
breakdown video of this scene before so
if you want to check that out I'll put
it up in the link above the next deleted
scene is of rocket talking to some of
the Avengers about how the Chitauri are
the suckiest Army in the galaxy ously
this is a comedy scene that they threw
in there for some laughs rocket is
making fun of them for not knowing how
to defeat the Chitauri to him it's very
easy you just simply blow up the
mothership and the rest of them died but
rocket is from space he has experienced
many different things in many different
galaxies the Avengers however have all
never left earth and this was most
likely the first time that an alien army
ever invaded the planet now ultimately
they discovered it by Tony Stark
launching the nuke into space destroying
the mothership and disabling the army
but like Natasha said it took a two to
three hour fight to figure that out
the next deleted scene is of Thor and
rocket in Asgard
Oh clear which way oh you say something
I said I want to call my eyes out but
unfortunately you weren't doing it good
because I already saw the awfulness will
you focus on focus this pretty place is
about to get are gonna fight real quick
by a bunch of freaking elves do you know
you know I saw all these people who died
so this is a little bit difficult for me
okay so why won't you reach down deep
inside and try and find a small humanity
this tomato page give me the thing you
think I come here
you're embarrassing all right which way
you don't know you used to freaking live
here for 1500 years not forever I think
yeah we have dead we are so so dead now
obviously this is another scene put in
there for comedy but it also talks about
the trials and the struggles that Thor
has been going through as well and he
also says a line that we heard in the
trailer but never heard in the movie he
says do you know I saw all these people
die now obviously we know that this day
is the day that the Dark Elves attack
Asgard and Thor - so a lot of us
guardians died this day including his
mother and again it's a comedic relief
but it also shows just how much of a
mess Thor is there's then another
deleted scene with Tony Stark and his
father Howard Stark at the military base
it's nutty it's crazy making because you
start worrying about a legacy you know
you want to leave them the better world
and then you realize you haven't done
all that much to give me one what's your
name again pots pots were come work for
me pots I'm a little tied up in futures
opinion it's a very brief extended scene
but it is an exchange with Tony and his
father as they leave the military bunker
and they're talking Tony talks about how
they both want to leave a better world
behind them he talks about the pressure
of doing that for their children and
during this part of the conversation
Howard actually offers Tony a job this
was obviously a big heartfelt moment for
Tony but the overall scene with him and
his father was pretty much a big
heartfelt moment so it wasn't exactly
necessary for the movie because Tony
Stark it does get the closure that he's
always wanted with his father in the
scene that we got in the movie and in
this deleted scene but there is another
deleted scene with Tony Stark and his
wife of course pepper these are coaches
they are not
what's wrong with ours you're out oh
what a glowing endorsement for all
Gerald is our up my pack up he's eating
my go geez okay they're gonna be nice
and salary no don't notice could you put
it down get out on my kitchen books
we're good here right yeah we're great
tell madam secretary lunches in five I
will collect email posters this scene is
supposed to be a reintroduction of Tony
Stark after the five-year time gap it's
a very brief but a very nice scene of
Tony and pepper preparing a meal for
their daughter Morgan the scene is
supposed to reintroduce us to Tony and
show what he did with his second chance
of surviving the snap he has a wife he
has a daughter and he has a new loving
family it was a nice scene to see but
ultimately didn't really matter to the
movie we still got to see his daughter
and the fact that he has a new family in
the beginning of the five-year time gap
when we see Tony for the first time and
the last deleted scene that we have is
of Captain America and a roadie then
what happened to the tesseract after
that it's bottom of the ocean fell out
of the plane after I had to crash you
yeah I've been meaning to ask why did
you have to crash the plane anyway
his mom's on board bottoms up boy and
you couldn't have jumped out of the
plane before you crashed it rody asked
Captain America a couple of questions
that fans have been wanting an answer to
for a very long time now since Captain
America the First Avenger Stephen rody
were talking about the history of the
Infinity stones and then rody asked
Captain America why the tesseract ended
up at the bottom of the ocean during
World War two Steve answers rody and
then rody asks why Captain America had
to crash the plane into the ice and
Steve simply tells him because it was
full of bombs but then rody asked Steve
the question that we've all been
wondering for a very long time
why didn't Captain America just jump out
of the plane before it crashed they both
kind of just sit there in silence and
right before Captain America is about
the answer the scene ends of course
Marvel is not going to give us the
satisfaction of hearing that answer so
those are all of the deleted scenes that
have come out with the digital release
of Avengers endgame which one of these
deleted scenes was your favorite and
which one would you have liked to see in
the movie let me know which one in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe like the video and
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
of course don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof